Sam, man. How did you last long with
Sam?
>> No, because that guy wasn't respectful.
>> I only like to talk I I I only like to
talk with respectful people.
>> I think that you know Sam is he's Sam
Sam is a hard one
>> to be honest with you. You're pretty
respectful so I don't mind.
>> I'm just smoother than Sam. That's all.
He just
>> he needs to learn from me in that way.
>> Okay. Okay. ready for uh uh the response
chapter 12 verse 111.
>> Sure.
>> So, right after I finished talking to
you last time, I actually talked with
one of my friends about this uh thing. I
asked him, you know, to help me out on
what this is. When it says it's an
explanation of everything, he said it's
an explanation of everything in the
natural world. So, anything that's like
what's around us basically is explained
in the Quran. That's what it means, an
explanation for everything.
>> Got it. So that also includes what the
Quran talks about, right?
>> Um, it's the opposite. It's the
opposite. Everything that's around us is
included in the Quran. It's not
everything in the Quran is talking is
detailed explanation. It's the opposite
of what you were saying.
>> You mean it's the opposite of what the
verse says?
>> No, the verse says it's an explanation
of everything. It's not everything in
the Quran. It's everything in the
natural world.
>> Okay.
So, so it
>> in other words, in other words,
>> so it has nothing to do with what the
Quran says. It's it's everything to do
with everything outside the Quran. It's
a detailed explanation of everything
outside the Quran.
>> The Quran has detailed explanation of
everything in the natural world. Yes.
>> Okay. All right. Let's test this out.
>> I I can even test it out. Yeah. I can
even test it out with some verses. I I
want to test it out, too.
>> Go ahead. Do you want me to start or you
want to start?
>> I want to start.
Okay. Um, how old is the universe?
>> How old is the universe?
>> You should be able to get that from the
Quran because it's detailed explanation
of everything about the natural world.
So,
>> I
that's a good one. Even even even us we
don't know. Even us we don't know
humanity.
>> So what God's supposed to know, right?
The Quran is from God and is a detailed
explanation about the whole natural
world.
>> Good point.
Anyway, anyway, anyway, anyway. Okay. Uh
and and another another interpretation I
got. Another interp wait. So is that
first interpretation false now? We we
scratching that off.
>> Okay. Okay. You you proved it false.
Another interpretation I got cuz I asked
many people.
>> All right.
>> So just one or two people. Uh another
interpretation I got
um where it says all things it does not
mean everything. So I can we can wait.
>> I I can explain. I can explain.
>> When it says all when it says all, it
don't mean all. Huh.
>> Yeah. I explain where they get the
>> Yeah. Go ahead.
>> All right.
So, I'll give you an example of verse
that says means everything. Chapter 46
verse 25. So, it says it's talking about
uh like one of the one of the uh the the
groups of people that were destroyed
because
>> I know and it talks about destroying
their houses, right?
>> Yeah. And it says everything was
destroyed. But it doesn't mean
everything in the world was destroyed.
It just means everything in the
civilization was destroyed. But yet that
verse says everything. So, so in that
verse we could we could clearly see that
everything here is not literally meaning
everything. And we can use that same
logic for chapter 12 vers.
>> Nope.
>> Why not?
>> I'll tell you why. Because in chapter 46
verse 25, it qualifies it. What do I
mean by that? It tells you what it's
talking about. So look, it says
destroying everything by the L. Now we
already know the context. It's talking
about those particular people is being
destroyed. We don't got to waste time
reading the previous verses.
>> So in context is talking about this
particular civilization.
And in this particular civilization, it
says in verse 46 uh verse 25,
>> destroying, let me put it on the screen
so we all see.
>> Yeah.
>> Destroying everything by the command of
its lord. So they became such that
nothing could be seen except their
dwellings.
>> Mhm.
>> So the their dwellings wasn't destroyed
but everything else was.
>> Right. Let's go to the context of
chapter 12 verse 111 because it has a
context too. Let's read just the
beginning.
>> 111 is about the it's about the Quran.
>> Let's No, it's about the stories of the
prophets. Read the beginning portion of
the verse. The beginning portion.
>> No worries. Let's let's So you're Let's
go with that. that in the beginning of
the verse it says in their stories is a
lesson for men of understanding. Right?
>> Okay. So let's go with that the Quran in
regards to the stories of the previous
prophets
>> is not a fabrication.
It's a detailed explanation of
everything. It's a guidance and a mercy
for those. Right.
>> And a and a confirmation of Yeah.
>> Okay. So we're talking about the stories
of the previous prophets. That's right.
>> That would include Adam, right?
>> Adam. Uh, yeah, that would include Adam.
Yeah.
>> What's the Who's his wife? What was it?
What was her name?
>> Um,
what's his name? Uh, yeah. Eve.
>> Where do you get that from? You don't
get that from the Quran.
>> Okay. Again, again, uh, the Quran has
context. So, uh, when it says an
explanation of all things about the
stories of the prophets, again, the
Quran says to, uh, to to basically
follow Allah and the prophet, we don't
we don't follow the Quran alone.
>> I'm sorry. Does it say that Muhammad is
an explanation of all things or that the
Quran itself is an explanation of all
things regarding the
>> It does not say the Quran itself. It
doesn't say itself.
>> So, what is it talking about?
>> It's talking about the Quran and the
hadith.
Wait. In 1211, what does it say is a
detailed explanation of all things?
>> Uh,
I need a refresher. Hang on.
>> Okay, no worries. We could look at the
verse again.
>> Yeah. Yeah.
>> In the Arabic it says it, but we know
what the it
>> Yeah. Well, I can I can argue it could
be referring to the uh to the Quran
hadith, but
>> No, you can't.
Okay. So, you think it's the Quran only
basically, right? You believe it's the
Quran only referring in this verse.
>> I mean, yeah. I mean, it's it's a it's
not a forged hadith.
>> What's not a forged hadith?
>> The the Quran.
>> A confirmation of what came before it.
>> By the way, it's not talking about the
Bible. It's not talking about the Bible.
>> No worries. Well, whatever. But the
Quran, right? It's a confirmation of
what came before it. Uhhuh.
>> A detailed explanation of everything
>> and a guidance and a mercy.
>> It's not the hadith. That's talking
about the Quran itself.
>> Okay.
>> All right. Now, so that means
>> but it's talking about Wait, wait, let
me go back. Let me go back to the
beginning of the verse. Okay.
>> Okay.
>> It says uh there are lessons from the
stories of the prophets. So it's it's so
let's let's go back. Maybe it doesn't
talk about everything about the stories
of the prophets, but maybe it talks
about the lessons from the stories of
the prophets. No, it doesn't say it's a
detailed explanation of all the stories.
It says it's a detailed explanation of
everything. So if you want to say
everything,
>> but you have to read the context from
the beginning of the
>> has to be about the stories of the
prophets, not just their lessons in
them.
>> No, but I'm saying the lessons in them
are a part of the the
>> I agree. It will it'll include the
lessons. It'll include the details of
who they were, who their wives were, who
their sons were, where they were.
>> That's not But it's not the story of
them. That's just the story of
>> That is their story. What are you
talking about? You mean to tell me that
somebody a story. If I make a story, if
I make a story like a biography of
something, I would talk about the most
important things of their lives.
>> That's that's
>> unfortunate. Unfortunately, it says in
their stories, the prophet the stories
of the prophets, their stories includes
their wives.
>> How do you how do you know that? How do
you know?
>> When I
when talking about the story of Adam, is
his wife mentioned?
No,
but it doesn't need to be.
>> Stop. Stop. Stop. Think about this. I'm
going give you a second to think.
>> Oh, yeah. Okay. Story of Adam. It's not
mentioned by name, but it's mentioned in
the Quran.
>> I understand. Is his wife part of the
story
>> as a side character? Yes.
>> Okay. So, she's part of the story. And
does the Quran give you the details
about his wife?
I'm saying it doesn't need to.
>> I didn't ask if it needs to. I'm asking
does it. Does it give? Okay.
>> So, if the Quran is a detailed
explanation of everything regarding
their stories of the prophets,
>> that means that it'll include the
details of the wives mentioned.
If it leaves that out, then it's not a
detailed explanation of everything
regarding their stories. It's missing
details.
>> I'm saying why would it need to give
detailed story?
>> Because it made the claim that it's a
detailed explanation of everything,
not some things. Everything. So if
you're trying to put it in the pocket of
or under the umbrella of the stories of
the prophets, I can work with you on
that.
So, regarding the stories of the
prophets, the Quran is a detailed
explanation of everything regarding the
stories of the prophets.
If it's lacking details, then that's a
contradiction and this verse is wrong.
>> Make sense?
>> Okay. So, there was a third
interpretation that I heard. Okay.
interpretation. Is the second
interpretation wrong?
>> Let's Okay, let's drop the second
interpretation. Let's go to the third
one.
>> All right, here. Third one's the charm.
>> Third one's the charm. Let's go to
chapter 3:7 cuz you said you tried to
make a contradiction out of it.
Let's go to chapter 3:7.
All right. So, it says the people who
are uh who just believe they follow the
similar verses or the unclear verses. I
I see similar verses. And then it says,
"No one knows but Allah." Here's a
problem.
After but Allah, they put a period next
to it. They should continue the
sentence. But Allah and the people of
knowledge
because in the Arabic you can put it
both ways in the Arabic.
>> I got you. So you want to go with the
interpretation
that not only does Allah know the true
meaning of those similar kind of unclear
verses
>> but the people of knowledge
>> so do the people of knowledge have that
same yeah
>> knowledge that Allah has.
>> Exa Exactly. Because it says
you can als you can continue the
sentence
and the people of knowledge. So you can
continue the sentence.
>> Okay. But some translations they they
make a mistake and put like a period
after except Allah.
>> No worries. Let's go with this. This
let's go with this. Okay.
>> Okay.
>> How does this help? How does this solve
the problem? How does this solve the
contradiction?
>> Because you said because you said the
contradiction is between this verse and
for example 12 verse 111 where you said
um
>> that it's a detailed explanation of all
things while that verse
>> and then you said and then you said
there are verses that are unclear. So
it's a contradiction. But I'm saying
>> the unclear verses you said nobody
except Allah knows the meaning of them.
But here I'm telling you no.
>> If you continue the sentence you can you
can you can make it except Allah and the
people of
>> I got you. I got you. So what do the
people of knowledge say means?
>> Some of them say Allah
or Allah you can
>> you laughed at this. You laughed at this
when we talked about this last time. You
laughed at their
>> Yeah. Yeah. I'm saying
just I
>> now you're not laughing at them now. Now
now they got the truth.
>> Yeah. Why not? Why not? Why not? Why
not?
What's the problem?
>> No. Well, I heard this online before.
>> I know. And you laughed at this, bro.
How do you expect me to take it serious
when you didn't take it serious? Now
you're trying to arc because it's your
last chance. So now you're trying to,
you know, give them the benefit of the
doubt. Like, yep. See, they I mark.
What' you say? I
>> Okay, I feel bad. I shouldn't have
laughed at them.
>> No, you should have because it made no
sense. It's silly. They're just making
stuff up. You're right to laugh at them.
>> You're absolutely right.
>> How do you know?
>> On on what basis are they coming up with
the meaning of what alaflim is? Because
other scholars say something. And again
the verse by itself 3:7 no one knows the
meaning except Allah. So maybe Allah
taught these people the knowledge of
>> right. So if Allah taught these people
the knowledge then they would have the
same knowledge. Right.
>> Yeah.
>> So why do they all differ?
>> Where does it say they differ?
>> You admitted
>> that they have different interpretations
on what that means bro. meaning that
they don't all have the same knowledge.
They're conflicting with each other. And
you want me to believe that Allah gave
them this? So Allah gave this person
that knowledge, gave him another
knowledge, and the knowledges conflict.
And that's all I was doing. He's just
sitting back and saying,
>> "Sorry, what's the last part you said?
Sorry, I had background noise."
>> Basically, that Allah is giving people
different knowledge that that conflicts
on the same verse.
So if uh so remember I told you they're
abbreviating it differently what means
they're abbreviating it differently.
Maybe all of them are right. Maybe all
of them are right.
>> Well come on brother.
Come on brother. There's only one
meaning to what that is. Not
600 different meanings that conflict.
Come on bro.
This doesn't work man.
The scholars don't know what alaflam
meme is. They don't know what these
these these letters mean, bro. Or words
or whatever they're supposed to be.
>> Again, there there's different there's
different uh groups of scholars that
have different interpretations.
>> I know. Which means that not even the
scholars know the correct interpretation
because they all differ on it.
Make sense?
>> Yes.
But how does that but how does that
solve the problem with chapter 12 verse
111?
>> It it it it doesn't. The problem is
still there. The problem is is that
according to the Quran, it's supposed to
be a detailed explanation of everything.
Yet it has verses that are not
explained.
So that's the contradiction.
like like let's even scratch let's say
37 never even like uh conflicted with
1211 let's say
>> okay okay
>> right let's just say that it never
conflicted it's pretty consistent with
it
>> that doesn't change the contradiction
that the Quran has that it claims to be
a detailed explanation of everything
>> while still having verses that are not
explained
>> but if chapter 3 verse 7 never existed
how would That still be a contradiction.
Uh oh. Oh wait wait wait. Let me let me
think back to what you just said.
>> Let me say it again. I'll say it again.
>> Okay. Okay.
>> Okay.
The Quran cannot be a detailed
explanation of everything
and at the same time have verses that
are not explained.
Understand? So regardless of what 37
says,
right? Let's let's imagine that I never
went to chapter 3 verse7 to show the
contradiction.
>> Okay. Okay.
>> Okay. Let's imagine I never went there.
I'm just showing the Quran period has a
problem. It claims to be a detailed
explanation of everything.
However,
there are verses within the Quran that
are not explained. They're unclear.
So that's the contradiction.
And then uh the last thing I heard uh
somebody told me.
>> So wait, is is the third one out?
>> Yeah, this is the last one for chapter
12 verse 111.
>> Last one.
>> Okay, this one I heard um the
explanation of everything.
>> They said it is an explanation of
everything, but there are more things
yet to be discovered in the Quran. So
the Quran is
>> so it's not an explanation of
everything.
>> No. So it because uh he went to chapter
18 verse 109 to prove his point.
>> Will those things be discovered in the
Quran or outside the Quran?
>> They're not going to be discovered
period. Go to chapter 18 verse 109.
>> All right. Chapter 18 verse 109. And
who's giving you this? a friend of mine.
Just a random friend of mine that goes
to my local mosque.
>> Okay. Is he older than you?
>> Yeah. Yeah. Like uh
>> he's a grown man.
>> Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. I go with him to
martial arts.
>> Nice. All right. So, chapter 18 verse
109.
Okay. say, "If the sea were ink,
for the words of my Lord, surely the sea
would be exhausted before the words of
my Lord would be finished, even if we
brought another sea like it for its
aid."
>> Yes. says he's using that to justify
chapter 12 verse 111
>> because the Quran
>> it's so great that some of the verses
like that that it's an explanation of
everything but Allah's words are so
great there are just some things that
are endless like I said the Quran is
endless you know
>> it doesn't say the Quran is endless it
says Allah's words are endless
>> Allah's words is the Quran for example
just
>> the Quran
How can you prove it's not just the
Quran,
>> brother? The Torah, Gospel, the Psalms,
Abraham scriptures, these are all words
of Allah, right?
>> Not what you have today.
>> I'm not saying what I have today. Just
simply just from what the Quran says,
the Torah, Psalms, Gospel, Quran, these
are all words of Allah, right?
>> Yeah. And then he also decrees things
that aren't necessarily in the Quran or
whatever, but he decrees things and uh
says things that are not necessarily
like even for example, you have the
hadith that has revelations from Allah,
right?
>> Only 40. Only 40.
>> All right. So you got about 40
revelations,
right, of Allah's words. So it's not
just the Quran. It's it's talking about
Allah's words in general. His words are
endless. They're infinite.
>> No, but he's putting the Quran into this
uh into this endlessness. It's not like
the Quran is a part of Allah's endless
words.
>> Yeah. The Quran is a part of Allah's
endless words.
>> Yeah.
>> From from what I heard, the Quran is
going to end one day. Have you heard
that same thing?
>> Um I heard in paradise, Muslims are
allowed to read the Quran. Like I heard
there's like a hadith where it says like
um uh in paradise I don't know if it's
authentic or not but somebody told me uh
paradise you know the people are going
to be together and then you know uh
Allah is going to be reading for them. I
don't know.
>> Are you laughing?
>> No it's just I heard it from some random
source.
>> But you're laughing at it.
>> No, I think that's a background noise I
have in my room.
>> No, you laughed, bro. You chuckled.
I feel like I feel like you kind of know
that this religion is done for.
>> No, no, it's not done for. It's not done
for.
>> Okay. Well, what do you think about
this? Um, you are you familiar with the
Quran verse that says that everything in
existence is going to be wiped away um
and going to pass away ex when all
that's left is Allah's face.
>> You're talking about chapter 28 verse
88,
>> I think. So, I don't I don't remember
the verse, but that's good on you to
remember that.
>> Yeah. But you know, you know what I'm
talking about, right?
>> Um, this is talking about um, I believe
before the day of judgment. I think
there's even a hadith that talks about
uh,
>> so doesn't that mean that the Quran's
going to pass away too because the only
thing that's going to be left is Allah's
face.
>> The Quran is an attribute of Allah.
[Music]
>> Everything will perish except I believe
it's
>> so going to perish one day. But since
the Quran is Allah's speech, Allah can
recreate it at any time. So
>> you're right. But do you see what I'm
saying? That's the point. The point is
is that it's not the Quran that's
endless. It's Allah's words that are
endless. And he can make another Quran
if he wanted with his endless words.
>> That's true.
>> It's about his words, not the Quran
itself is my point.
>> Uhhuh.
Now, even with this, it doesn't solve
the problem that
the Quran claims to be a detailed
explanation of everything,
but some of its verses are unexplained.
>> No, that's not. I think I think what
he's trying to say is Allah's uh wait,
hang on. It's an explanation of
everything.
Oh, yeah. I guess it doesn't. I I need
to do some more. I need to find a fifth
or sixth reason.
>> There is no
There is no fifth or sixth reason, man.
It's over. Just admit that I fulfilled
the challenge and you have to leave
Islam today. You should have left last.
>> You did not. You did not. You did not.
Okay.
>> I did. You said I did.
>> Can we go back? Can we go back to the
first challenge about some
>> No, you said you said I completed it.
Let's Can we go back to that first
challenge about this?
>> No, you you're supposed to leave Islam
now.
>> Listen and this and this and this and
this and let's go back.
>> Let's go back to the one that you said
about
listen. Let's go back to the challenge
that you you you brought up, right?
>> No, you already I want to address that
one too. I want to address that one too.
>> All right. So, at least for now, can we
s Can we admit that at least for now
there's a contradiction in the Quran?
Uh, I just need to do more research. So,
>> right. But as for now,
>> for now,
>> but but yeah, but I I it's not
definitive.
>> It is definitive,
>> brother. You tried everything. And I and
what for one one thing I want to do
>> is I want to give you props because you
you genuinely tried like you went and
you asked somebody more knowledgeable,
multiple people it sounds like.
>> Yeah.
>> Or and you got these different answers.
You remembered them. You I don't know if
you did you write them down.
>> No, no, I have a
>> Oh, you you just remember.
>> I have a very very very good memory.
>> You do for remembering verses like this
because I didn't even remember this
verse and you was like, "Oh, 288." So,
you got a good memory. But I want to
give you props. You went, you
researched, you asked, and you brought
the answers back that you thought were
possibilities, and you were like, "Okay,
let's see what he says to this." And you
see, and you're being honest, that none
of these explanations work. I I love
your honesty. Do not change for me,
Jobber.
>> I'm not I'm not I'm not I have to be
genuine.
>> Okay. So, if you're being genuine, we
have to acknowledge the Quran has a
contradiction. At least for what we see
right now.
>> For right for right now. For now.
>> Okay. All right. Look,
>> now let's go to the Let's go to the
thing, right?
>> I don't I don't have time. I don't have
time. It's I'm at the three-hour mark. I
got to go. Oh,
>> but I will I'll be live again.
>> Let me ask you a question. Let me ask
you a question.
>> Let me ask you a question before I
leave.
>> Okay.
>> Do you know any other Christians that
use Streamyard? Because I don't have Tik
Tok nor Discord. Do you know any other
Christians that use
>> Oh, you trying to go to battle with
them?
>> You trying to go You You want the smoke,
huh?
>> You want the smoke, bro?
Oh, no. Cuz I'mma be if I see you on
somebody else's panel, I'm gonna be a
little jealous. Man,
>> you can come up on stream, too. You
know,
>> I'm be like, man, that's my guy. Like,
he's supposed to be on my stream. You
know,
>> the only reason why I picked you is
because you're the only one that I know
on Streamyard. Everybody else
>> I'm just I'm just the only one around.
Huh? So, man, look. Okay, I'm gonna give
you some names.
>> I'm listening. If they
>> I'm I'm banned I'm banned from Sam
Shamoon, so I can't go to him.
>> Okay. No. No. Sam Shimoon. If they
disrespect you and if they're rude to
you in any way, let me know. I'm gonna
handle them. You got me.
>> Okay. So, Sam Shamoon is already on the
list.
>> All right. I'mma handle Sam. Okay. But
um All right. So, you got King Silv.
>> How do you spell it?
>> S I L V.
>> Okay. Got it. Okay. Hold on. sale. You
also got
um the word and I. So, it's the word
>> and I.
>> The and symbol or is it is does he spell
it out on here? I'm not conf does does
the word and I spell out the word and on
his channel or does let me just check. I
don't know how I'm doing this. Let me
just check.
Hold on, let me just check.
>> And by the way, all these channels use
StreamYard, correct?
>> Huh? Yeah, they all use Streamyard.
Yeah, they all use Streamyard. So, okay.
So, the word and I, it's spelled and so
the the word and I. No, no space. All
one All one thing.
>> All one word. Okay.
>> Um,
he's actually gonna be live soon. Um
Um, Jai and DLC. So, I'm gonna put it on
the on the screen. They actually show
it. Like,
>> is it two channels or one?
>> It's one one channel. It's a husband and
a wife, but they're like young like me.
>> J N DLC.
>> J A I
>> Space Space and Space DLC. Okay.
>> NLC. Reloaded.
>> Reloaded. Interesting.
>> Their first channel got cancelled
because there was a Muslim woman that
gave them false copyright strikes.
I know. Um, Giant DLC. Who else am I
leaving out, y'all? Word King Sil. Giant
DLC. Uh,
um, Maverick. Maverick was just here.
Maverick, he What does? Wait, I don't
know if Maverick uses Streamyard. I
don't think he Streamyard.
Uh, Rob Christian uses Streamyard.
Does Rob Does Rob let up guests? Rob.
Rob be on Tik Tok.
Nick. Oh, yeah. It's Nick. Nick, let me
Oh, no. His uh his uh YouTube channel is
>> Truth, correct?
>> Yeah. Yeah.
>> I tried, but it's not Streamyard. It's
some different website. I I don't know
the name. It's like uh
>> Really?
>> I I don't know if it's stream. It's some
other website. I think it's like
>> OBS. Yeah, you probably
>> Yeah. Yeah. It doesn't It doesn't work.
Uh like I guess there's like some I
don't know, something you have to do to
get in. for example, like streaming
artist. I can hear you there. I couldn't
hear I couldn't hear him. So,
>> okay.
>> I tried.
>> All right.
Um, and then
you got God Logic 2.0.
>> He uses Streamyard.
>> Yes, he uses he uses my same Streamyard
account.
>> Okay. Cuz uh one time uh I tried jumping
on and I couldn't stay for long, so I
had to leave. But then when I tried
joining again, uh he took down the link.
>> Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. Go ahead. Go ahead and
cook them, man.
>> Um,
Yep. All right. That's good.
>> Thank you.
>> You're welcome, man. Have fun. Don't
Don't embarrass me, man. I'm sending you
to these people, so
>> No, no, no, no, no, no. I I'm not gonna
I'm not going to embarrass anyone.
>> All right. Go cook them, man.
>> Okay.
All right.
>> Anyway, see you later.
>> See you later, Jer.